hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to a little game called
lame the phobia
got ice cream in the intro screen huh
yeah this is a very very very very very
alpha obviously by alpha 0.13 you can
see it's very early release in the game
of an experimental indie horror game so
I'm gonna give it a try
link is in the description below if you
want to play it and here we go
doom kind of like what I'm about to go
you are a PhD student collecting some
weather data in an aircraft over an
unexplored area everything was going
well when suddenly hello ollie HAP good
lightning strike my plane I'm gonna say
yes Wow Oh
oh this looks good just had a crashing
tonight didn't I I guess I'm lucky to
have survived that anyway this game is
powered by Unity engine as well oh
really
what is it safe I picked up a know we
see four notes thank you unknown in such
find three orbs and be free hey there's
some numbers on the bottom there I don't
know what they mean they might be sacred
I'm not sure I'm not sure what the
actual objective of this game I didn't
even know you crashed in a plane but
anyway it's made on the same unity
engine that the Slender games made on
the roof of an gps device that's are for
looking at
oh hello oh that's easy I'm leaving
vegan or oh thank you - 68 by to see my
510 68 5 to 60 ah
wait there's a there's a mountain in my
way I'll high up in the mists Skyrim can
I go straight up the mountain looks like
it man I'm a great climber look at me go
hah I forgot this friggin skull
good god mother no one what the hell
going on why why did that pop up why did
I do that
oh my god Oh Davis God first the whisper
and then the skull popped up Daisy
oh hey Haleh phobia you're not you're
not happy fun times how do I get up the
mountain is that's where the first dorm
is oh don't look don't look at it
oh okay well no it'll be nice to know
before okay I might be on a bit of a
time crunch here because those guys kind
of came out of nowhere I didn't know
this this game would be this bad
reversed 188 which one which is a little
more manageable 188 to 80 120 here to a
1 going editor 21 188 and then I just go
to 281 there we go
this way don't fit this over here and
here okay 281 kuwaiti it's got a keep
going until I find you and go straight
from here 188 up going down a bit 281 oh
this was is bad oh oh is that oh don't
get stuck on a tree that stuff happens
when I get stuck in a tree good or bits
so mystical and no oh no oh no oh no 489
456 I'm going this way 956 okay no not
again no I can sprint but it's barely
faster than my normal run speed yeah
borniche I forgot with the numbers or
god damn
really well burning not fun ah oh god
damn it
good boy Evan oh oh oh seven nine five
six weeks
mm sick days I get this way run run I
don't know if I have like a sprint meter
thing but I'm just I'm gonna run okay
seven eight seven hundred seven six
hundred something I don't know I'm like
that Terra's over zone doesn't give you
don't know something singsong oh don't
get me look at me jumping forward
you're jumping Jobi hey dummy you're
jumping
dumb fun no let me go I'm rerunning 700
and gentlemen 600 and tummy hurts dude
over here is nearby gotta be I got
chicken Oh - you have a 95 degree yeah
every night okay okay I don't know if I
take up running okay Oh be free am I
free am i God to be God
that game was awful nobody play that
game
I've never villain I've never felt more
chaste in my life like us but I was good
that's good
okay oh man
oh man that was amazing honey for an
early alpha game that I did that was
really well put together tears I got
like sweaters marks where my arms were
laying down no it's a freakiest thing
I've ever played in my life oh man oh I
don't want to do that ever again but you
guys should try it
that was awesome
oh man I mean I guess I guess when I now
that I'm thinking about it aside along
comes a lot easier to get away from the
skulls and I thought so I just made a
beeline towards New York so there's a
lot of room for development there
there's a lot of stuff that can happen
it's pretty solid
oh man anyway links in the description
below so click on it play for yourself
skip you got the hiccups out
something that should scare me yeah so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye